l'avocat du chef christophe leroy qui
étend la tourmente
christophe leroy depuis quelques jours
il accusé notamment d'avoir organiser
des dîners clandestins rémunérés et
maître thierry fradet est avec nous en
face time c'était important qu'on l'ait
ce soir et qu'on est également sa
version ce qui a tellement de gens qui
parlent de ça merci m fera d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup
alors aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
en mesure de nier totalement laissée qui
sont reprochés à votre client le chef
christophe leroy
d'abord il faut que je fasse une
introduction malheureusement de la magie
tient simplement à vos gars avec un
certain nombre de règles déontologiques
le souci de satisfaire les intérêts de
mon client sans florent l'occurrence qui
doit être un terreau des très très
prochainement dans le cadre vous
comprenez bien que je ne peux pas
rentrer dans les détails factuels le
dossier à l'antenne ça ne serait pas
pour autant qu'ils aient accepté de
venir avec plaisir c'est bien pourrait
vendre certaines questions légales
requises afin de compliquer dans ce
qu'on va arriver à une certaine
manifestation banalité sans que vous
retombe sua ne ferait pas sérieux
je mes livres 1 quel point tu as a eu
sous mes yeux ce prêt pour pêcher saq
sûrs de nous dire aujourd'hui ce que
veut m est ce que je suis en mesure de
dire et je vais reprendre votre question
on ne me demandait est ce que vous êtes
en mesure de nier les faits qui lui sont
reprochés à votre client il ne conteste
pas les faits c'est à dire d'avoir plu à
certaines occasions servir des repas
dans le cadre de manifestations privées
dans des domiciles privés avec des gens
qui étaient là dans un esprit de club
donc dans un cadre qui n'est pas soumis
à la réglementation générale d'alterner
demandé question je m'amuse ennuie pas
très amusant mais on est là pour ça
aussi il ya un peu de droit
alors j'ai pas vous lire la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du mois de mai
2001 mais quand même quelques petits
princes qui parce que je pense qu'on
part dans tous les sens dans cette
affaire premièrement tout ce qui n'est
pas interdit est autorisé
ça paraît évident qu'il faudra pour
dossier manifestement par les dictatures
tout ce qui est pas interdit est
obligatoire
on en n'est pas là tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit nous et quand même autorisé de
chaque affaire est régi par un principe
constitutionnel de d'ailleurs le premier
c'est la liberté d'entreprendre et le
grand emprunt qui constitue le plein
c'est la liberté quand même et elle afin
qu'ils constitutionnel et malika de
bompas et de faire ce que l'on veut ce
soir donc
christophe laurent lorqu'il était
intervenu de manière générale je ne vais
pas parler de ce qui a pu se passer ce
jour là je voulais il a pu le faire il
ne l'a appris que dans un cadre
strictement où les intentions ne
s'applique pas d'ailleurs sous d'autres
cieux
j'ai réclamé en vain qu'on me fournit la
seule équipe qui alterne une enchère de
venir chez quelqu'un à son domicile
effectué une prestation haut mais ce
n'est pas bien alors alors perdons si ça
n'existe pas a dit m oui de deux petites
remarques la première le magicien nous a
dit tout à l'heure qu'il avait visité la
galerie vivienne et c'est un musée et
que pour y aller il faut payer donc
penser que les musées étaient fermés
première chose pour le côté résidence
privée et deuxième chose je pense que
quand on reçoit des gens avec un chef
privé à domicile on ne communique pas
sur plusieurs menus avec plusieurs
reprises sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya un vrai besoin de communiquer
quand c'est privé on communique par
voyez donc je trouve que voilà c'est un
petit peu bancal et je ne comprends pas
trop cette ligne de défense
les pays les visites date mais je vais
répondre à vos deux observations qui
sont capitale les raisons d'ailleurs
merci de poser des questions
premièrement oui des gens sympas ici pas
les reins sont à l'aise je vous ai dit
que je ne répondais pas fini
spécifiquement aux problèmes des villes
bien d'accord j'ai été clair là dessus
d'eux puisque vous me donner une forme
de tentation du caire une observation
aux dites vous même que le palais fermé
par devient le dit fier des vies mais ce
challenge d'accord on est bien sur leurs
annonces
du privé je ne parle pas du de la soirée
litigieux je raisonne schaaf est la
première chose
deuxièmement vous faites part de votre
émotion selon laquelle il y aurait eu
des effets de fer parle de publicité
d'invitation je ne sais pas comment
appeler ça voyez l'émotion et il n'y a
pas de traduction du raid hic dans tout
cela
il fait qu'on ressorte il se dit indigné
que cette musique n'a pas de sens pénal
la loi n'interdit pas vous ne vous
interdit pas vous d'organiser un repas
et la liberté valenciennes n'a dans
l'île et demain miseho un déjeuner 200
personnes en matière à venir 2 il faut
le ca ressort
le conseil constitutionnel a dit partir
du moron il s'agit d'un domicile la
réglementation des ailes d'annexion ne
peuvent pas être appliqués et d'ailleurs
lorsque vous allez sur le site du
gouvernement
on procède par suggestion par conseil on
explique qu'il faut pas être que je suis
la femme est là tout le monde a connu
pas plus de 6,4 mètres carrés pour
chaque fête avec les rats il n'y a pas
de fonction on ne sanctionne pas le
département de cette suggestion
juridiquement par une quelconque amende
parce qu'il s'agit d'un domicile c'est
la liberté mais thierry fradet juste
parce que vous êtes assez mal m thiery
trad est juste il est où votre client
aujourd'hui il est dans quel état tu
resteras parce qu'on sait que tout le
monde me dit que c'est un garçon
délicieux c'est un amour de mecs qui
avaient des difficultés mine de rien
parce que voilà et qu' il est maintenant
des soirées privées même qu'on croyait
pas et qu'on me voit là pour essayer de
votre de s'en sortir
il est dans quel état christophe
aujourd'hui il est attachant et 9 ans de
médias côté très humain qui confine
voilà la faiblesse un da ilha
effectivement il sortait la tête de
l'eau
regardez
comme une fusée d'ailleurs c'est bien
pas n'avaient pas de restons donc je
suis là feraient d'ailleurs cette
nouvelle activité est une activité qui
l'avait fait justement pour parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas énormément de moyens les
petites robes d'ici là cette action et
celle de servir d'arabe et des retards
et j'ai pu le faire dans un restaurant
et qu' il est signé de créer si vous
voulez des rencontres autour de la
nourriture parce que ça dans un esprit
club dans les homicides privé et pour
répondre pleinement que tu as non à
votre question
quand il va comme un gibier les envie de
dire qui a eu l'honneur derrière lui est
en train de lui courir derrière il n'a
pas très bien sombre et bras face il
chante qu'il est pris en otage
je répond d'ailleurs à la question
n'avait pas posé dans une affaire où
manifestement ça fait cinq jours
d'affilée de hull à 100 se demandent si
elle est un membre du gouvernement va
pas se cacher la face
j'ai regardé les chiffres des élus le
faire du ministère de l'intérieur il y a
eu ces quinze derniers mois 1000
verbalisations ont les mêmes faits que
ceux qui dans l'absolu qu'ils étaient
vraies elles sont reprochés ça fait les
flammes jours de suite là une offre
l'émotion ces coins-là des réchauds y at
il eu ou pas de gouverner ça on a envie
l'ennuyer ce gouvernement est claire et
même dans cette affaire il y en a pas eu
donc là encore sans rentrer dans les
détails de ce qui a pu se passer ce soir
là puisque remettre un projet vu
différemment là dessus je vous affirme
qu'il n'ya pas eu de membres du
gouvernement
merci maître thierry sera des urnes
lorsqu on aurait là non exactement